hello and welcome to this episode where
we are going to talk about the European
Union's proposal for an artificial
intelligence act it was proposed by the
European Commission on the 21st of April
2021 and very recently on the 14th of
June this year the European Parliament
has voted on it the whole AI Act is a
document of almost 90 Pages it also
comes with a 10 pages summary see the
links in the description below in this
video we summarize and break down the
most important points for you and tell
you why this is important for you even
if you're not an EU citizen but not
before we thank assembly AI the sponsor
of today's video assembly AI offers
super human AI models for speech
recognition automatic transcription
speech summarization and more through a
secure and scalable API as an applied AI
company assemblies ai's mission is to
empower app Builders to build 10 times
faster focus on their specific use cases
and user needs and win market share with
a true technology partner last week
assembly AI announced its new conformer
2 model the company's latest AI model
for automatic speech recognition that
was trained on 1.1 million hours of
audio data now this week assembly AI is
launching lemur the easiest way to build
llm apps on spoken data users can search
summarize ask questions and generate new
text with knowledge of all an
applications spoken data lemur performs
internet retrieval to offer a high
quality llm responses with a single API
call you can play around with
post-conformer 1 and Lemur in their free
AI playground with the link in the
description below now back to the video
the EU has a draft on the AI act so it's
not yet enforced as it is still to be
approved and adopted by the member
states so why did EU feel like there is
a need of an AI act because on the one
hand AI can benefit Society by helping
science improving Health by finding new
drugs for example it can help us with
protecting the environment it can help
in transport by optimizing bus routes
and estimated time so for Rivals it can
help feed the population by optimizing
agriculture in the list of the benefits
can go on and on but on the other hand
AI can also have some questionable uses
for example it can help social media
companies make more money because AI
algorithms help them make you stay
engaged on their platforms such as
YouTube and even worse AI is a
double-edged sword that can be used in
even more concerning applications such
as face recognition at scale so social
scoring and many other applications that
Empower discrimination cut on the
freedom of expression and can harm data
protection and privacy
so the aim of the euai ACT is to
regulate AI to protect its citizens from
harm enabled by AI while still fostering
AI Innovation for good applications it
is important to understand here that
this AI Act is by design of product
safety regulation think CE label on
electronics safety standards for
personal protection equipment and so on
and it is not intended to slow
technological advancements but rather to
make sure that the eye products on the
market don't harm anyone the who wants
to step in on AI matters especially
since so far authorities cannot step in
when it comes to uses of AI an eu-wide
regulation would avoid fragmented
Countrywide measures that would make
using an AI produced and regulated in a
EU country difficult in another one a
clear stance of governments on AI would
also make the current situation better
in which the legal uncertainty
discourages businesses to use and rely
on AI systems and I think it's
understandable that I am a bit dissuaded
to use AI generated pictures in my video
because who knows if following a new law
I might be banned in the future from
showing my videos with such content in
the US or another country the world so
far has been quite slow in making laws
about AI much slower than the
technological progress for example the
United States were very hands off in
regulating AI so far and who knows
whether this might change with the
recent Senate hearings this AI act draft
makes the U the first to have a serious
regulatory proposal on AI then let's see
what the AI act contains to whom does
this regulation apply well besides the
new rules would apply primarily to
Providers of AI systems established
within the EU or in a third country
placing AIC systems on the EU Market or
putting them into service in the EU as
well as to users of AI systems located
in the EU interestingly it does not
apply for military purposes but what
does even count as AI according to the
EU we know that the definition of AI is
very debated even by experts so in this
draft AI is and we quote software that
is developed with specific techniques
and approaches listed in Annex one and
can for a given set of human defined
objectives generate outputs such as
content predictions recommendations and
or decisions influencing the
environments they interact with end
quote do you agree with this definition
there are stakeholders who think that
this definition is too broad and they do
have a point since this definition even
applies to a simple search through the
internet if powered by a neural network
should that be regulated too Miss coffee
Bean's take here is the following it
does not matter how AI is implemented
but its application she does not care
what the technology or algorithm behind
the task is but the task itself like
should we care what their face
recognition is implemented by the latest
in machine learning such as deep neural
networks or is it a very complicated and
lengthy if else algorithm it's the
application that matters the problem
that advancements in AI brought so far
is that before we could not do face
recognition or defects at scale and now
we can if the definition of AI is narrow
and only includes deep neural networks
then one could circumvent it within its
if else program for example and you
would say but there is no super
complicated if else program that does
face recognition but what if I take a
neural network that does face
recognition use another neural network
to transcribe me the patterns of the
first Network into a humanly impossible
lengthy to write if else algorithm so in
my opinion not the technology but the
applications should be regulated and
we'll see this is the way in which the
EU goes as well where not the technology
but the task it solves is the one posed
under scrutiny
so how does it do it to regulate the
software well by distinguishing between
AI systems posing unacceptable risk high
risk limited risk or low or minimal risk
unacceptable risk would be prohibited
because it is considered to be a clear
threat to people's safety livelihood and
rights such unacceptable risk AI would
use manipulative subliminal techniques
curious what that means or would be
exploiting vulnerable groups with
physical or mental disability Social
scoring is also unacceptable or
biometric identification such as face
recognition in public spaces but there
are exceptions in cases like serious
crime if a new arrest warrant has been
issued remote biometric identification
systems may be used
as for high risk systems they create
adverse impact such as biometric
identification and categorization of
natural persons management and operation
of critical infrastructure education and
vocational training employment worker
management and access to self-employment
access to and enjoyment of essential
private services and public service and
benefits law enforcement and so on these
high risk systems will be following new
rules they will need to receive a CE
certification registration just like all
electronics toys personal safety
equipment and so on that are sold on the
European market for that they need to
conform to the safety legislation of
their own field just like medical
devices are and to another range of
requirements such as risk management
testing technical robustness data
training and data governance
transparency human oversight and cyber
security all checked by a third party
before being placed on the market or put
to use
as for AI of limited risk these are
systems that we cite interact with
humans are for example chatbots emotion
recognition systems biometric
categorization systems and AI systems
that generate or manipulate image audio
or video content such as deep fakes they
would be subject to a set of
transparency obligations end quote and
these requirements include a description
of data sources for training the model
inclusion of standardized benchmark
scores and disclosure of machine
generated content
on the first glance these obligations
maybe seem reasonably easy to comply
with but none of these current
Foundation models from gpd4 stable
diffusion to even luminous which was
created as a more you friendly model
could comply with these obligations if
they were in place today this study from
Stanford University Center for research
on Foundation models shows that for
example almost all models except for GPT
Neo X or Bloom use copyrighted data for
training or did not disclose that they
did not use copyrighted data very few
models disclose the compute and energy
requirements their data sources or
conduct extensive evaluations or testing
and lastly for low or minimal risk AI
the EU imposes no obligations there will
be AI supervisory and civilians
authorities at National level to
supervise the implementation of the
regulation and administer fines
depending on the severity of the
infringement up 30 million or six
percent of the total worldwide annual
turnover to Foster developments and
encourage startups the commission
proposes regulatory sandboxing which is
we cite a controlled environment that
facilitates the development testing and
validation of innovative AI systems for
a limited period of time before they are
put on the market sandboxing will enable
participants to use personal data to
Foster AI innovation without prejudice
to the gdpr requirements end quote since
none of this is implemented yet it is
easy to feel unsecure about how this
will develop since we do not know yet if
every nation will be able to assemble a
worthy Board of experts on this
will the AI act also apply to research
we got to ask this question in our
interview with the EU Parliament members
in charge of the AI act themselves and
the answer is no this AI act will not
really affect researchers as long as AI
is developed and released as research
and not as a product it does not fall
under this regulation so a website with
a model demo from research or code to it
should be fine but when a company is
making money by making it a product it
falls under the regulation if you're
using AI tools yourself for example to
generate images or by getting help from
chatgpt to write text these regulations
will likely not affect you very much as
this regulation has its basis in product
safety regulation the major focus of it
is to make sure companies don't put
products on the market that impose a
danger on consumers but as an individual
you are free to use the products that
are certified As You Wish what you might
see are watermarks to indicate generated
content as such which come as part of
the transparency regulations for limited
risk AI systems of course if you want to
use an AI system that the EU deemed
unsafe to use you will not be able to
get access to it in Europe
and I know many of you are not from the
EU so you might think that this does not
really affect you but the past has shown
that regulations that apply to the
European market often affect the global
market as well since a lot of producers
sell to Europe and must conform to its
standards this is known as the Brussels
effect just like with the California
effect in the U.S companies that try to
sell their products on the global market
will often try to comply with the most
stringent standards available this way
they won't have to design different
products for different markets and will
still be able to export to the whole
world this was already the case for the
production of chemicals airplane
emissions and more recently data
protection where now major U.S tech
companies implemented the European gdpr
compliance for all their customers even
outside of the EU
and this was our summary about the AI
act what are your thoughts on this I
think it's a good start but we will see
how it develops as stated by Mr tudoraki
in our interview it will take a while
until the law will come into effect
maybe we will need to wait until 2026
but surely companies that want to become
future proof may want to already start
complying with the new rules in fact
while preparing this video seven leading
AI companies in the US have signed an
agreement to put some safeguards on
their products for now this is just a
voluntary self-regulation but it is a
first step if you want to hear firsthand
from The Regulators check out our
interview on the channel of the European
Parliament we hope you like this video
and don't forget to subscribe to also
see our next one
okay bye
[Music]
[Applause]